3:02 well I made a devil with a spork in
criminal cop news submitted by Wes from
Seattle several cities in Alaska are
employing dozens of police officers with
criminal records so Cooke cops yeah
did they not ever do this before maybe
they don't have time they don't have
enough people if you have a record or
even what are the crimes that's a good
one cuz if it's like two kids yelling a
cop probably before that before Phil is
if you had a felony it was automatic
disqualification I don't know if they're
taking felonies now or they're taking in
people with misdemeanors but also I know
a bunch of people that were criminals
they just never got caught and they
became police officer oh yeah to me like
the overall concept isn't new but then I
guess on paper that's where it's like it
and if you're hearing this for the first
time your pilot oh those criminals that
become Casa my new drug dealers that
became caught yeah but I always think
that they're the minority not like like
like a lot of us true yeah not really
convicted drug drug dealers really mom
nothing he's got away with yeah cuz
these are convicted criminals of assault
domestic violence and that but to me
there's no difference it's just one got
caught in one didn't yeah like whether
you sold drugs and you got convicted or
you did it your book is here that the
people hiring are like we know you beat
your wife up and we know you did this
and that but we're still gonna give you
the job to take care of the yeah yeah
yes yeah so like most likely if you did
that you're gonna walk into a domestic
violence house holding you're gonna be
like it's alright bro don't worry she
deserved it you know what I'm saying as
a postman I've been there brother yeah
interesting
no thanks that'd be tight yeah so at
least 14 cities in Alaska have employed
police officers with criminal records
but a lot of these criminal records
they're the ones that should have been
prevented from being hired in the first
place cuz they're like pretty bad ones
yeah like some of them are felonies and
stuff like they shouldn't have a cop job
and so they're saying that they found
like these there was this news
organization
that found out that more than 34
officers who should have been an
eligible for these jobs got the jobs and
then in all except for three cases the
police hires were never reported by the
city governments to the State Department
of Public Safety which is required so
like so the police department is
committing crimes to pretty much even
the trees so that means they knew about
the crimes and then they're just like
bucket I like you
pretty much I'm sorry I'm imagining
they're all small town cops with friends
you know very small town okay they're
saying that the reason why this is
happening is because it's been a lot of
budget cuts and there's just not a lot
of people like the only people that are
really looking for jobs as a cup are
criminals and there's the whole town has
a record day whatever um well whoever
it's trying to apply has a record the
unemployed who were trying to get jobs
yeah yeah and so well sometimes I think
criminals make the best cop because they
know I can see it they know they know
and then bill though they'll battle them
but it also depends on how long it's
been since that crime or their if
they're rehabilitator yeah or if they're
gonna help the criminal feel like a
criminals have probably been through so
much and police officers see so much
throughout their day that they have so
much trauma inside of them that I can't
imagine someone who already has like a
bad mentality of the world going into
that work field and then having to go
through so much more again you know like
they'll probably treat people like [ __ ]
mmm cuz they're over it or whatever like
recently the governor who he vetoed
millions of dollars for the village
Public Safety Officer program which had
started in the 70s so a picture of the
governor no I just picture a guy with
like sunburned face and like sled dogs
in Alaska yeah come on little burner
yeah goggle no goggles dude yeah the
[ __ ] phone
wurst do you figure another way back oh
oh yeah I forget there's white people in
Alaska like for some reason it was all
like straight-up Inuit in my head yeah
Sarah Palin's from out there yeah okay
okay last week no anyway she vetoed that
funding and he said that the reason why
he veto days because 17 out of the 55
authorized positions were vacant and
that the funding they just have an
inability to spend these dollars in
recent years and that was his reasoning
but that same day the federal government
announced that it would declare a law
enforcement emergency in rural Alaska so
they authorized one and ten million
dollars in immediate funding and so
they're saying that the US Department of
Justice said that Alaska has the highest
per capita crime rate in the country and
that some of the money would go toward
hiring equipping and training village
Public Safety officers hi is but you do
you know why though because over there
like it's probably they don't have son
for a lot of the years but honestly no
and so people are probably like sad and
it's always dark you know like it's it's
just more it's easier to just do things
and get away with them maybe that's more
wrong - you can you can get away with
[ __ ] yeah like everything is probably
far as fun yeah imagine how much
graffiti you can do if it's like 20
hours of night who's gonna see it no
one's gonna see [ __ ] don't go there
genius social science experiment on how
they lower the crime rate by adding more
light in a parking lot and stuff so then
maybe you're right about the whole
darkness is like there's more crime
because it's just even think about like
when it's winter here and like
everyone's [ __ ] sad like she's still
on depression sets and and the does the
crime rate go up at that time of the
year I think every one sec cause they
live in LA I mean I'm not sad in the
summer I'm sat in the winter I don't we
get winter depression the way the East
Coast weather does he must feel like
winter well to me it does it does yeah
cuz I can be walking around like this
like I really want to can't you double
down and in the winter these well I
guess it's relative risk to where you
come from because if you're from a
tropical area then yeah it is pretty
like coldest now where the
close a year around I don't even feel
like we have a winner but I guess if
you're from like Hawaii you only feel it
like in early morning or late night yeah
once it's a noon it just feels the noise
feels you've been going now I don't like
going on in winter because it's cold
like with what you could like what I
could wear I guess like a dress or
whatever I feel like how am I gonna wear
sweater with this you know that's crazy
cuz I thought as well Alaska was doing
well and don't they have like universal
basic income in that state and all that
[ __ ] well they have a program that the
oil profits go back to the citizens they
get a little bit of oil money yeah yeah
but yeah I don't know I had no idea I
had a friend though that moved out there
to work at different like Chinese
restaurants cuz they didn't have a lot
of workers and he would tell me like he
would fly to different cities for shifts
Wow and they were paying him like
20-something bucks an hour that's
nothing right
that's very easy yeah like that's how
much business they were getting and they
didn't have enough workers so that might
be the reason why like there's not
enough workers so then the cops oh
they're all yeah we're not enough cops
yeah 20 an hour plus tips yeah yeah Wow
so he's just taking puddle jumpers over
there something yeah I think they're
like little planes or whatever but he
grew up like right here Monterey Park
and then he left to the workout Daniel's
I want to be a resident because he was
telling me that once you become a Alaska
State resident you get money to from the
government yeah and there's no like
taxes that we have it's like not the
same well cuz nobody wants to live over
there yeah you know it's cold it's dark
electricity is cheaper
you could mine a Bitcoin there fairly
cheaply because it's already cold how do
you know this wait what do you mean 30 I
don't know perhaps I have researched if
you like fishing Bitcoin miner at some
point but what do you mean it's cold I'm
confused by like oh that's cold
no but the Bitcoin thing okay so yeah
you and your mining it's very hot it's a
hot practice and so if you already have
the air around you cool you can just run
fans and have the air or anything cause
that's much all the computers get huh
yeah yeah the computer
Computers whining Rick gets hot as [ __ ]
yeah I see yeah
really hot like for example the mine rig
that I bet he was [ __ ] with your
efforts no the mine reliable yeah you're
right yeah big as this table and it
could heat this whole [ __ ] room up
like crazy like we're all like dripping
sweat Wow because it's a hot boy so if
you do this in like China or somewhere
humid and hot you have to spend more
money on cooling everything down with
these pins lock tons in China to mind no
no you need to explain this so there are
the Alaskan residents alarm that
criminals are becoming cops or is it
like other people outside looking in
like oh [ __ ] this looks like a scary
place to live no the residents
themselves they're saying that for
example this one quote says it's
outrageous that we have a situation
where we where we have a such a lack of
Public Safety that communities are
resorting to hiring people who have the
propensity for violence and placing them
in a position where they have control
over people and possibly could victimize
the victims further so yeah people
living there are not happy yeah it feels
like the like the old frontier like
their shows on yeah you know like the
Gold Rush shows are like whatever like
and it seems like they just live like
old school you know like organ trail
style where it's just them and their
family with guns and bears and all kinds
of [ __ ] and I'm like dad's crazy man if
it makes anyone feel better though like
then the police they still have to do a
police academy
and so if there's like a normal academy
it's like probably like six months long
and it's Monday through Friday and you
gotta wake up at 4:00 you gotta memorize
all these penal codes and stuff so like
if you are a criminal there is a chance
of rehabilitation it's like a pretty
hard process to become a police officer
so it's like you can all across the
board in the US yeah six months is fast
yeah it is fast yes it's pretty fast but
it's also extremely strenuous yeah so
it's like it's not it's not no I watched
police academy this comedy chair with a
record who can identify and sympathize
with say a wife-beater some [ __ ] yeah
that's the scary that's very scary yeah
but hopefully through the training the
six-month training and it's all day long
that it can help change and they wake up
indigo wife-beating is wrong Oh
she also built a camaraderie with fellow
police officers and there's good and bad
cops and the Academy and then you have a
tio it's like a training officer that
when you come out so hopefully there's
like enough rehabilitation that happens
where they can maybe I'm hopefully I
wish they spend more money on like
therapy for police officers oh they need
it for sure for sure dude because like
once you go through the six month period
like yeah it's so hard and it's like all
due respect to all police officers you
know but I think at some point you get
to like where you're in the work feeling
you're like oh [ __ ] what's easier this
or that and then a lot of people take
advantage of their power yeah and
there's way more good police officers
and bad ones oh yeah but there is some
bad ones that you're just like damn how
did you get into this position so to
have someone who already has a record
and can have affairs
you have to investigate themselves yeah
dude have you guys seen the videos of
how fast cops have to react just some
situations that their training
the way that they do their training is
so [ __ ] crazy the way that somebody
could just pull a gun on you and a
random traffic stop is nuts yeah like
those training videos I recommend on
anybody that's what I don't even blame
like police officers for getting like
over aggressive sometimes cuz just you
don't know if they already if that if
that situation where someone pulled a
gun out and they have to block that
gonna go hey stop freeze you don't know
if that's the first time that they did
that that day or they just experienced
that nine times earlier and now they're
on high alert yeah or a cop is just
chilling at a Denny's and somebody comes
up behind them and pulls them away yeah
[ __ ] that just happened the other day
yeah yeah a lot of a lot of cops get
killed and I think what we see in the
news is cops killing just citizens but
they also don't know like how we've done
yeah the media doesn't report cops
getting killed all it like that happens
in LA all the time yeah we're statistics
man the University of I think was
Michigan just released a study that said
that it's it's less likely that cops are
going out that a white police officer is
gonna kill a black citizen and it's
actually more likely that a black police
officer would kill a black citizen
because they were raised in those
communities so they're more familiar
whereas a white cop is more likely to
hesitate
because they are thinking about
headlines and they want to give
everything the benefit of the doubt in
light and in the headlines and they're
afraid yeah of that of that situation so
there's a delay in their response times
it's [ __ ] fascinating [ __ ] that blew
my mind yeah
[Music]